hallo deutschland am freitag
und wir starten direkt mit unserem
corona kompakt wie immer mit den
neuesten entwicklungen im überblick
unter anderem beantwortet der virologe
professor platter gleich ihre fragen und
an der polnischen grenze stehen
berufspendler ab sofort auch unter
quarantäne
eine letzte berührung über die
deutsch-polnische grenze hinweg ein
polnischer junge verabschiedet sich von
der zwillingsschwester seiner mutter sie
bleiben in deutschland die tante bleibt
den polen ab morgen
ich kann nicht mehr hin zum frankfurt
zurückgehen weil ich muss die 14 tage
fand an die haben dann ich bleibe hier
mit meinen sohn
und weil wir leben hier in polnische
berufspendler in deutschland die bisher
problemlos zwischen den ländern reisen
konnten haben seit mitternacht eine
schwere wahl zu treffen wenn sie zurück
nach polen reisen müssen sie dort für
zwei wochen in quarantäne
entsprechend dramatisch sind gestern
abend die letzten stunden vor
inkrafttreten der neuen regel ein paket
als letzter gruß an die familie in der
polnischen heimat
ich kann nichts kommen morgen über die
grenze weil die grenze ist einfach zu
und wenn ich komme dann kann ich nichts
zurückgekommen und meiner familie
bleiben ohne und das ist heute die
wirkung der neuen regel so gut wie kein
verkehr auf der brücke über die oder bei
frankfurt brandenburg und mecklenburg
vorpommern fürchten dennoch um ihre
polnischen arbeitskräfte mit einer tages
prämie von 65 euro wollen die
bundesländer polnische pendler zum
bleiben in deutschland bewegen plus 20
euro für jedes weitere familienmitglied
das hier lebt 11 infizierte gibt es
bisher in der stadt menden am rande des
ruhrgebiets +45 kontaktpersonen wenn
sich einer der betroffenen nicht an die
quarantäne hält wird er möglicherweise
demnächst zwangsweise in der turnhalle
untergebracht wo bereits notbetten
warten
das infektionsschutzgesetz sagt
wenn menschen nachweislich infiziert
sind und andere in die gefahr einer
infektion bringen sich an die quarantäne
vorschrift nicht halten dann sind diese
menschen anderweitig unterzubringen und
das ist die verpflichtung einer jeden
kommune in der bundesrepublik
deutschland zwischen den betten sollen
noch trennwände aufgestellt werden
die zahl der neu infizierten in
deutschland erreicht leider neue
höchstwerte
laut hopkins universität sind bis heute
nachmittag 47.000 373 menschen in
deutschland positiv auf corona getestet
worden
5673 haben die krankheit überlebt
professor wurde platter ist biologe an
der uniklinik mainz und jetzt unser gast
professor das virus lässt sich nur
sieben tage auf den schleimhäuten
nachweisen sind tests danach dann
überhaupt noch wirkungsvoll
wir sind der tag zunächst mal vermehrt
sich das virus im mund rachen raum
dann kann man es auch gut nachweisen mit
einer ganz normalen methoden
dann wandert das virus ganz
offensichtlich bei den meisten nach
unten in die lunge und verschwindet
möglicherweise oben aus den
schleimhäuten im nasen-rachen-raum lang
kann man es da auch wirklich nicht mehr
nachweisen unter umständen zumindest
nicht per abstrich aber gibt es dann
noch eine möglichkeit in der lunge zu
gucken ob das corona ist da kann man
unter umständen wenn zum beispiel eben
die patienten schwer krank sind auch
material gewinnen aus tieferen atemwege
und dass dann dort nachweisen sind
vielen dank für den moment denn sie sind
noch weiter unser gast und beantworten
dann zuschauerfragen ja vieles muss
anders laufen momentan auch beerdigungen
gehören dazu aber gerade das abschied
nehmen
das ist wichtig um den tod eines
angehörigen zu verarbeiten
aber wie geht das ohne näher oder ohne
umarmungen
die beerdigung ist vorbei der
verstorbene zu grabe getragen
doch wer kentrup und seine frau editha
haben als bestatter neuerdings noch
einen letzten dienst den sie den
angehörigen auf wunsch erweisen ein
selbstgedrehtes video von der beerdigung
ins internet stellen wir haben das in
absprache mit den angehörigen den
pfarrer gefilmt werden dieses video
gleich ins bestatter portal hochladen wo
die angaben an zugangsdaten zu bekommen
und dann ist heute abend im
familienkreis diesen film anschauen
können besonders für diejenigen die
nicht dabei sein durften
denn das corona virus beschränkt auch
den zugang zu einer beerdigung nur der
engste familienkreis darf teilnehmen
kinder ehepartner und eltern nie mehr
als zehn personen wir andere
bestattungen gewohnt sind wo wirklich
die familie die freunde alle kommen
zusammen um abschied zu nehmen und das
ist im moment nicht möglich
der pastor darf kein wasser mehr
verspritzen wegen der infektionsgefahr
und sie dürfen deshalb auch keine
schaufel mehr ans grabstellen von der
die erde auf den sarg rieselt die fast
jeder an und es gibt nur noch vier statt
sechs sargträger distanz ist das gebot
der stunde
auch drinnen die stühle in der
aussegnungshalle stehen in gebührendem
abstand sich umarmen sich halt geben
auch das nicht mehr gestattet fällt uns
allen sehr schwer dass wir den
angehörigen noch nichtmals die hand
geben können zur begrüßung dass die
angehörigen sich in ihrer trauer auch
gar nicht um rahmen können oder
eigentlich dürfen wobei wir festgestellt
haben die meisten machen
doch daran habe ich auch wieder gesehen
wie wichtig das ist dieser zusammenhalt
das schlimmste für die angehörigen ist
aber dass sie ihre liebsten gar nicht
mehr zu gesicht bekommen
sie werden von den mitarbeitern im voll
körper anzug im krankenhaus oder
altenheim abgeholt kommen im körper
säcke und dann in den sarg und der wird
nicht mehr geöffnet
da ist das so dass wir den verstorben
haben jetzt in dem sinne eingebettet im
krankenhaus in einem verschlossenem sagt
und dürfen jetzt in dem sinne keine
weiteren meist maßnahme treffen sondern
müssen die verstorben so wie er ist
leider in seinem sack beziehung senden
sagt lassen
wir dürfen keine hygienische maßnahmen
mehr treffen sprich wir dürfen wir ihn
nicht mehr waschen desinfizieren und
ankleiden wir halten uns daran dass der
sarg geschlossen ist weil wir nicht
wissen woran derjenige verstorben ist
weil das nur in einem geschlossenen teil
des totenscheine steht es geht uns
nichts an das fällt unter das
datenschutzgesetz und insofern hand
haben wir das so als wenn derjenige auch
zurzeit corona hätte haben können
dem sarglager haben sie immer einen
ausreichenden bestand und sie hoffen
dass ihnen italienische verhältnisse
erspart bleiben
das erschreckt mich kolossal wenn sie
überlegen das verstorbenen lkw militär
lkw transportern überführt werden
da geht ja völlig die pietät verloren
und die anderen haben gar keine
gelegenheit mehr sich zu verabschieden
oder der verstromung zu begleiten in
form einer trauerfeier beerdigung das
geht uns schon ziemlich nahe
kein abschied nehmen weder in italien
noch hierzulande distanzierte
trauerfeier
das ist nicht tue man sagen sie in der
zeit darauf mit den angehörigen macht
wenn die jemanden verloren haben sich
nicht verabschieden konnten die
beerdigung nicht so stattfinden konnte
das weiß man ja erst dann im nachhinein
was das mit den menschen macht
makabres detail am rande sie haben auch
probleme dieses infektions mittel zu
bekommen denn ihr gewerbe gilt nicht als
systemrelevant sie werden beim einkauf
von schutzausrüstung nicht bevorzugt
dabei brauchen sie die zum selbstschutz
und auch bei den trauerfeiern
die verwirrung ist groß wie kommt das
wäre es denn nun ganz genau in den
körper was ist wenn ich beispielsweise
eine türklinke anfasse wie lange halten
sich viren auf oberflächen
was sie neben dem händewaschen noch tun
können um sich zu schützen
so sieht es aus der nähe aus dass corona
virus den zig fache vergrößerung
im täglichen leben ist der erreger und
die gefahr die von ihm ausgeht leider
nicht so deutlich zu sehen
umso wichtiger ist es da sich zu
schützen aber wie genau gelangte das
corona virus eigentliche den körper
tröpfcheninfektion ist der hauptweg also
wenn jemand infiziert ist und beim
niesen oder husten vor allem dann die
viren ausscheidet und wenn man nah genug
dran steht nimmt man die viren einfach
dann direkt über den eigenen über die
eigenen atemwege auf das kann übrigens
auch schon bei einer ganz normalen
unterhaltung passieren zweiter möglicher
infektionsweg neben der
tröpfcheninfektion
die sogenannte schmierinfektion über die
hände
wer als zb in die hand hustet und die
zur begrüßung später einem anderen
reicht kann die viren so weitergeben
kommt die hand dann in kontakt mit den
augen der motor der nasenschleimhaut ist
eine infektion möglich nächste frage
überträgt sich das corona virus auch
über oberflächen also zb über das
smartphone die türklinke ein geländer
oder ähnliches
das von anderen atemwegserkrankungen wie
zb der influenza und es ist ein weg der
möglich ist der hauptweg ist aber ganz
klar das direkte anhusten anniesen bei
ersten laboruntersuchungen hat sich zwar
gezeigt auf karton oberflächen kann das
virus bis zu 24 stunden überleben auf
plastik oder edelstahl sogar zwei bis
drei tage allerdings ist laut bundesamt
für risikobewertung bislang kein fall
bekannt in dem sich ein mensch über den
kontakt mit einer kontaminierten
oberflächen oder über ein kontaminiertes
lebensmittel angesteckt hätte wie
schütze ich mich also ganz generell
gegen eine corona infektion regel 1
händewaschen gründlich und regelmäßig
also beim nachhausekommen nach dem
toilettenbesuch die nase putzen dem
niesen vor dem kochen oder essen und
nach dem kontakt mit kranken und zwar
mindestens 20 sekunden die hände
gründlich waschen dabei wirklich alle
partien an den händen berühren abwischen
also mechanisch und seife und wasser
genügen wichtig auch regel zwei direkte
kontakte meiden
wir wissen dass diese erreger eben sehr
ansteckend ist also ein infizierter
mensch steckt üblicherweise so zwischen
zwei und vier andere personen an
das ist viel mehr als zb bei der
normalen grippe da sind es weniger als
zwei menschen die ein infizierter
anstecken damit verknüpft deshalb auch
regel drei abstand halten zu anderen 1,5
bis 2 meter empfehlen experten vor allem
um andere zu schützen ist da noch punkte
4 wichtig fust und nis regeln beachten
wenn ich symptome einer
atemwegserkrankung habe wie sonst auch
darauf achten dass sich einfach andere
nicht anhusten nicht an diese das heißt
mich wegdrehen oder in die armbeuge
husten und niesen
außerdem gilt auch beim husten und
niesen abstand halten zu anderen
außerdem taschentücher nur einmal
verwenden und dann waschen oder
entsorgen
das erklärte ziel ist das ein zudem
professor puerto plata ist virologie an
der uniklinik mainz und beantwortet
jetzt zuschauerfragen zum beispiel von
regine böttinger geheilten patienten
haben doch antiviren gebildet ist es da
nicht möglich diese anti viren zu
züchten und zu vermehren
also antivir gibt es natürlich nicht
sondern sogenannte antikörper
das ist nichts anderes als ein teil des
immunsystems der immunabwehr die da
gebildet werden
die kann man tatsächlich zum teil eben
auch auf reinigen aus dem blut von
infizierten was man auch machen kann man
kann die auch gegen täglich herstellen
sauberer weise und dann unter umständen
einsetzen aber da ist immer noch relativ
weit davon entfernt tatsächlich ist ein
längerer prozess
dann fragt es köhler es gibt im
supermarkt feuchte als weg tücher und
sprüher einiger fürs bad kann ich damit
auch meine türklinken ausreichend
desinfizieren
die müssten eigentlich hinreichend was
entsprechend auch einwirken lässt diese
mittel auf den türklinken um diese viren
zu deaktivieren das funktioniert
eigentlich ganz gut
muster alkohol drin sein oder das ist
natürlich sollte eigentlich drin sein
und entsprechend den sie also sagen zum
beispiel die auch entsprechend diese
diese viren auch in aktivieren wie wir
sagen okay doris mittag fragt die
verkäuferin fast zum beispiel brote mit
den händen an
auch das geld kann ich mich so mit dem
virus anstecken würde auch immer wieder
gefragt das ist eigentlich ein sehr
unwahrscheinlicher weg sich anzustecken
und außerdem meine erfahrung dass
mittlerweile auch in bäckereien zum
beispiel brot und entsprechende produkte
auch mit handschuhen angefasst werden
auch das ist ein sehr unwahrscheinlicher
weg wie man sich anstecken kann tanzen
wolfgang heise schreibt kann man
zugestellte post aus dem in und ausland
ohne risiko öffnen
da geht's eigentlich das gleiche auch
auf diesen oberflächen können zwar wie
eine gewisse zeit halten aber in aller
regel ist das alles nicht hinreichend um
sich zu infizieren und auch da gilt
natürlich wie auch gerade im beitrag
gesehen natürlich wenn man sich die
hände wäscht und ins gesicht fasst dann
besteht da auch kein risiko
und wie fährt es sich generell mit viren
zum beispiel an paketen oder an
zeitungen türen das kommt ja immer
wieder oder auch verpackungen also ist
es bei allen kann man das sogar es im
prinzip das gleiche
natürlich können auch mal wieder auf
eine türklinke sein aber auch da gilt
natürlich wenn man sich die hände
entsprechend oft wäscht und vor allen
dingen versucht nicht ins gesicht zu
fassen was schwierig ist dann hat man da
eigentlich auch kein problem
ok ursula fragt bringt es etwas für die
bewohner und pfleger eines seniorenheims
wenn ich waschbare masken mehr
das wird zunehmend auch tatsächlich
genommen auch der kreativität ist da
keine grenze gesetzt war es auch immer
wieder jetzt neue masken liefern auch am
tag mitarbeiter wenn gemacht werden
das kann man verwenden und das ist auch
tatsächlich schützen und der vorteil ist
etwas aus stoff macht man kann das dann
entsprechend auch waschen also
regenerieren kann sich muss dass eine
bestimmte temperatur dann haben das
sollte natürlich über 60 grad sein
mindestens 60 grad schon längere zeit
dann überleben dass diese wir in einem
boot
petra jansen fragt was sie gerade schon
beantwortet haben bei welcher temperatur
steht das virus kann ich eine maske zum
beispiel aber auch andersrum in der
tiefkühltruhe desinfiziert und würde ich
nicht raten ihren möglichst gerne kalt
das heißt da kann man durchaus damit
rechnen dass die auch längere zeit an
überleben während sich auch im labor zum
teil eben wenn man damit arbeitet auch
in gefrierschränken konzentriert das
heißt also das ist sicherlich kein guter
weg mit den maßnahmen um diese ziele
natürlich dann auf jeden fall die
hitzewellen jansen fragt wir nutzen
einen wäschetrockner in einem
mehrfamilienhaus kann man diesen auch
noch nutzen wenn jemand aus dem haus mit
corona infiziert ist wir zum einen wird
man ja natürlich im wäschetrockner mal
gewaschene wäsche rein tun dass die ist
ja schon mal sauber und dann ist der
interveniert 60 aber natürlich der
trocken auch so heiß dass auch das
natürlich die die wir nicht überleben
das wird die wäsche üblicherweise noch
nass und wenn dann ein messer und hitze
dazukommt dann werdet ihr das nicht
überstehen
das klar vielen dank für die
beantwortung der fragen der professor ja
und bei uns geht es weiter mit dem
corona kompaktes können sie natürlich
jederzeit auch im internet nachgucken
und zwar auf youtube auf dem kanal der
zdf heute außerdem können sie uns weiter
ihre fragen schicken die e mail adresse
dafür ist corona kompakt zdf.de und alle
informationen die bekommen sie natürlich
auch jederzeit auf heute.de in den
nachrichten um 19 uhr und direkt im
anschluss daran dann auch noch in einem
zdf spezial das heißt corona krise
wirtschaft wankt jobs in gefahr und das
sehen sie um 1925